does this moment feel to know you made
this movie and now it is nominated it's
got to be big feedback here on the red
mark well the nomination is the win you
know I'm happy to be here it'll be a fun
night I hope Kimmel's funny so I don't
go to sleep and if they call my name
I'll be surprised but whoever they call
I'll know that I'm in good company with
these other directors what did it feel
like to get that nomination that's great
maybe it's something
there'll be worthwhile yeah that's very
modest yeah how is baby how's the baby
large yes five weeks old event tux
celebration of daddy now are you doing
Suicide Squad I don't know I just met
some guys about story points it's not
it's not a done deal or anything but
it's just fun to shoot the bull and own
when it comes to the stories I love
doing it and if I get we can elevate any
kind of concept that's good so you're
ready if it happened to rabwah see we're
gonna wrap you up but since you do have
a lot of kids you got any advice for
Clooney
any advice for who Clooney George
Clooney with multiples aren't there
you know we may lose some sleep no
hippie good Hill digger
he's he's a person people
you